intervention gas is a very good example
right will it really be replicable
elsewhere in the world it's the success
of North America is that going to happen
in China and South America and maybe in
more modest form here that's not very
certain look at the policy debate as a
public debate about fracking people
don't really sure right and why should
we do that but if uncle venture gas is
successful it really doubles the
previous thought resource base of gas
and then it really makes it a real game
change you can really go for different
type of energy systems in a sense that
you can early gains replace coal by gas
but su build and big infrastructure
system on gas also you start opening up
options for the future I will call it
say you have room to maneuver in 2020
2030 s because you haven't gas
infrastructure which is also easily as a
little extra cost they make suitable for
hydrogen gas or liquid hydrogen so
actually my count you're lucky because
you have an infrastructure you can
piggyback on if you do in other routes
then you don't have the infrastructure
and then it becomes very expensive to
introduce hydrogen